each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hi Thank commie it's my pleasure to
introduce the DR Horton he is currently
a postdoc at the UIUC and he got his PhD
from the Institute of automation in
chinese academy of sciences and today he
will tell us his work in UIUC on the
emotion sensing forget you I want to say
thank you 10 yo for offer to invite me
to visit MSR it's my great pressure to
be here introduced to my research the
topic of of my talk today is a machine
understanding of audio and visual
effective expressions you're welcome to
ask you a question and if you are
watching the my presentation on online
if you have any question in the comments
please send an email to me so this is
the outline of my talk first I we are in
seduced a motivation to answer the
question why the research is important
and then i'll give the brief description
of the history of the factory condition
research then I were introduced the the
three studies we did about audio-visual
effective expression analysis then
finally I well give the summary and and
I talked about Challenger we have the
face in this the research so emotionally
involving the element in the human daily
life that some emotion well you reach
the meaning of the communication some
emotion will motivate the people action
so in modern society people are spend a
lot more time to study and playing and
walking and
even living in the computer computing
world so the FL recognition system the
provided away enable the computer to
understand and express emotion and
provide the way to build the effect the
support environment computer environment
so here at least some of the application
the one is the the computer editor
nemesis and I will talk a little bit a
detail give example so you know the in
the learning the environment still and
expects to experience the series of
failure so but anyway it should people
have a different threshold to the
torrents the confusion and the failure
so if the computer can understand the
change of the effective estate of the
student so they they can provide a
probability that the two three strategy
or the help students engage this
learning the procedure another vacation
is a customer service specifically the
cost Center the mission call center so
if the machine can understand effect
states of the color they can respond
appropriately or even though has to
control to the human operator another
easily intelligent automobile system so
right now the several automobile company
investigate the possibility to build the
system to detect the fatigue so in order
to monitor the vigorous of the driver so
you know in order to reduce the extent
the the people right now spend more and
more time in the online communication
actor used to MSA but the people many
use the attacks to transmit the messager
so after a recognition system to provide
the possibility to build the
affect the bandwidth so you know so in
this way I can affect the recognition
system can you reach the communication
another application is the game and
entertainment of examples are the xbox
because you know the when people are
playing the game the involve a lot of
the emotion so if the gaming system can
detect the change of the players like
the weather the player is aboard whether
it's a frustrated whether he is his it's
interesting interested so the the game
system can adjust the gaming system and
so helped the player to engage this kind
of that the game another applications
video indexing and the retriever so
right now there are several website
which provide a way for the people to UM
upload the videos in the website so the
effect the recognition system provided a
way to analyzes the video so the
categorized terrorize the videos in
terms of the human affected states for
example for example the comedy the video
the tragedy video scaring video or
exciting the video so this can help the
user to search the video according to
their preference another is a
electronical customer relationship with
Mark marketing so we believe the effect
of recognition system can can help the
company together the feedback about the
province the attitude of the user to the
specific oh the product of the
advertisement
or the service so that's helped the
coming to survival in the competitive
environment so another important
application of effective recognition
research is in the affected related
research in this in the social sciences
like psychology psychiatry and education
especially when notice that more and
more people are engaged exploring the
mystery of emotion in our daily life
because the emotion is pay the important
role in the human creative and the
perception memory memory decision-making
and health so here I give example of the
the human effect recognition can be used
in the computer aided and an assistant
this is is a it's the prototype of
multimodal human computer system which
was a building in an SF idea project are
well I was privileged to participate and
working with in the disparity in front
he's found engineering and the
psychology so you can download the video
in the ITR website so in this
environment the student is sitting in
front of if sitting in front of the
computer avatar and innocent environment
you know there's no keyboard MMO no
mouse with just a lot of the camera the
microphone so specifically this the
camera to our is used to check the
facial expression to analyzes the
emotional state of for the student and
there are set of the inflow camera to
monitor the eye movement to infer the
engage engagement of of the student
and there is a set there is a one camera
two is used to monitor the task state
and a microphone to detect the keyword
the microphone to detect the keyword of
the of the subject is speed speech so
this is this the task of state and then
so basically all the information from
the multiple sensors and then so the
avatar will ever look can make
appropriate that the tutoring for
example the encouragement and guidance
and the transition so this is a so this
is an example of the effect reckoning
system can be used to improve student
performance help them to engage your
learning and in the long hand help them
the beauty in Chester for the science
and math so we have any questioning ok
so then I will talk about the history of
the effective recognition research which
is based on our recent the survey I
wrote I wrote in with the major pancake
and gaining roizman and the tom vaughan
while working together make this a
comprehensive the survey so here I just
used the one slide because of a time
history i just use the one slide it'll
give the whole picture and he's the
history of the effect revenue research
so actually the effect in effect the
recognition research study the three
decades ago the win ian is stephen in
1972 Hootie to the the initial efforts
to the use the computer
analyzes affect the recognition reckon
effect expression focus on the audio
expressions in 1978 the sewer and he sat
in research 18 did earlier work in the
facial expression analysis so then the
are we notice there were significantly
increasing number of the efforts toward
this kind of effect expression
recognition folks on the unimodal the
methods in 1990 a a study was conducted
in a group by the librarian and
professor Tom Horn who they did read the
work of the audiovisual the displayed
analysis about the facial expression and
so in 2002 before that before the
two-time to most of the efforts are
focused on the post the emotion that
means that the data was collected to ask
the subject to our house they are
expression in front of the camera or the
microphone so in to time to there is
days study was was investigated that
spontaneously displays focus on the
audio expression in 2004 well we notice
the days the study focus on the vision
based spontaneous ways conducted by
their jeffrey cole and his research a
team they they investigate the
difference that between the post the
fish expression and the spontaneous of
facial expression and in the same year
we did some work already their work
study the audiovisual the non basic
emotion but there are most of research I
focus on the basic emotion or called the
prototype emotion expression including
the happy sad fear anger disgust and the
surprise but a way noticed there's some
the Communist County vanda motivated
states are very important of a human
computer interaction for example dove
interesting the board and a frustration
and a puzzle so we did study to analyze
this this non basic emotion for HCI and
in 2005 when other day I sir is the
study who you investigated or the visual
spontaneous displays in the based on the
data collected in the human-computer
interaction actually it's a Wizard of Oz
scenario so in 2006 we did a spontaneous
expression analysis using the data
collected by the psychological study
called adult attachment interview this
is based on the human to human in
interview so Union so the in this field
the most of existing the studies are
folks are the Uni model imager process
the is limited with the facial
expression or the audio processor
process the expression ok Oh spontaneous
is a different therefore we can call
this the real emotion expression in
other words
for the UH because right now the we did
this study we first focus on because you
know the emotion data it's very
difficult reflecting because it is very
subtle and very shocked so the people
started this research just like ask yeah
actor stager asking to go to I saw the
question um I heard that Ross micarta
media lab people had been doing a lot of
motion stuff so would you have video lab
hmm in the prevention MIT oh yes rustic
our end oh yeah yeah yeah sure sure they
are we wrote a second in the book about
the affective computing yes the kingdom
um they chief of she under her that
researcher King folks on the first that
they study the local folks on the
physiological expression so well anyway
in our server table we are also excited
that he heard the paper in this field so
they also did some research about the
physics classroom and he it is something
they are very interesting look about how
to use them the muddy water for example
faking scratching and posture and the
physiological responses the combined
together being persistent so recognized
I think Liam that i was listening okay I
only sort of perfectly know that yeah so
I mean basically I feel looking much
more than audio people to get much more
than ordering video and we've always
looking in certain contexts so these
most of these studies are in general
context oil but if you're looking at the
context when you are
the student who's trying to solve a
problem versus a driver who started
driving and there is stress so those
those kind of emotion recognition
applications will much more focused on
the certain context but they did
incorporate x and x audio sometimes
video and often the direction was to
incorporate multiple modalities iphone
yes this is a very good discussing also
we notice that the contest is very
important for the arm for the emotion
recognition because you know the
emotions to be in a situation that the
human experience or imagined so you
without the contest will be sensed an
expression especially the sometimes when
people are judge the expression for of
the ambiguity so the context is a
constraint to accurate the joining of
about the expression so I focused my
efforts on on the other visual
expression and their spontaneous
displace in this field and this this
also we did the survey also notice the
destitute rains here one change these we
are one more people shifted the efforts
of pantyhose a expression to the
spontaneous expression and from the Uni
model analysis the modern model analysis
even the video based analysis people
Israel now is exploring the integration
of the the phase extraction and the body
gesture and had a woman so the audio
based the analysis the people also
explored integration of the linguist in
the party waste to improve the
performance of recognition of effective
behavior
so we move to the next section which
well I will talk about our efforts in
this field the first I want to talk
about is Marcus to infuse a treatment
for the visual effect expression
recognition while we we focus on I first
on the other visual expression we can
explain front psychology of respect and
engineering perspective the front-engine
psychotic perspective a lot of the
studies demonstrate the importance of of
the integration of information from the
effector relating the modality together
the coherent the interpretation and
judgment of emotions because the how
does the emotion judgment is a year post
profit the actually the emotion include
generally speaking the emotion include
the five elements wines behavior another
note of behavior another is the other
state county appraisal and acts in
tendency and physiological responses and
subjective feeling so actually a lot of
other for example 2x action tendencies
the subjective feeling and the economy
price so we can gather any information
from in our communication so we most
most of the time we judged the emotion
just the based on the behavior are
especially audio-visual an expression so
all the fonda engineering the
perspective oh you know all the
multimodal fusion providing way to make
use to make use of the comprehensive
information fund that if in the modality
and the reduced the limitation for
technical for example the the image
processing are sensitive to the
illumination and the opposed the chain
an occlusion the speech analysis is
sensitive with the the noise so combine
the audiovisual modalities it's a
provided the possibility to reduce the
delimitation of attacking technology I
studied this research on the data
collected in a group which is collected
by Larry turn and the professor Tom
Horne they collected data asked the
recept the subject to the polls the 11
affected states including the seven
basic emotion states and for the
cognitive state as I mentioned before
interest the borden frustrating the
puzzle because we believe that states is
a cognitive and a motivated state it's
very important for the HCA
human-computer interaction you now
expander we use the 20 subjects 10 mil
and attend females and the each subject
asked her to express the audio visual
expression three times so the first step
of the effective recognition is a
feature extraction we use the 3d fish
tracker was developed by the taller and
a home 1999 called the piecewise basing
basing volume the deformation tracker to
track the 12 facial emotion unions
around the mouth eyes eyebrows and
cheeks so this is the picture for free
sweetie fish tracker for the audio part
we use the because there's a lot of a
study indicated the coloration of the de
prosti and anna and emotion state so we
now study way we use the peach manager
the formant and the full bandwidth as
the audio feature so the first
experiment way there is is we try to in
this kind of a
the class we can't ask what feature are
most important what future contributes
them most in this kind of a task so we
we use the back for the feature and
selection and the forward feature
selection to analyzes the contribution
of the different the features in this
classification task so here the this is
the less experimental result the x-axis
are represented the feature number from
the 12 12 is represented the 12 motion
units to facial moon motion unit fund
the 13 to the 24 representing the
derivative of for this 12 facial motion
units the the y-axis is the frequency
that means the number of occurrence in
the future snagged subset so high freq
the feature with the higher frequency
means they contributed the more in this
classification the task so in our
experiment especially the backboard
features integrity and the forward
feature selection when notice' the
action Union seven and eight
representing the wrong moment
contributed the most in this
classification task oh the featured
around the mouse contributor last
because at least the feature are related
they're both of the speaker content and
emotional state
physics / two-year mission communities
is more than turning 40 just then it's
just a good product no you said it's a
is it honey for but the chest this shows
the 20 50 but the actual is 24 it's a
friend of 12 the 24 so I know Kessler
will use the 24 then put the 24 feature
different this injustice or checkers
yeah so the number just a minute the
future no neurological like you talking
about Fisher auctioneers I thought I use
Fisher King giggles hmm oh it's not a
future activities it's emotion units oh
yeah yeah it's a it's a defined by our
system it's a different of foreign
entities oh you're different of Jack's
Union the teachers develop of the pipe
or a coma right so you mean so for the
audio features in action we use the
feature a nurturer and the full men and
the bandwidth and that they are
derivative corresponding the derivative
to do this kind of feature selection
experiment Alex talent show the picture
and amateur contribute the most in the
audio expression recognition so the most
important der for the ought of other
visual expression recognition is how to
integrate the information from this
different modalities to get the better
performance so for example suppose we
have a 3 string of the feature or three
string of signals so for this sequence
we we can use the atrium model to model
them independently the most of the
methods right now people used is used
first is each streams I'm all older
independently
and then the output of each modalities
of the different modalities are combined
at the end so they put together the
integrate but we call the multi-storey
in the independent hmm it's a so when
when the abuse the component a German it
did it don't care the observation of the
other streams so it's a so actually they
lose the dependence of different streams
so our efforts is to try to build a
model to make use of the coloration of
the difference dreams so we propose the
multi strangest hmm so this the
theoretically is the based on this
equation this equation is according to
the maximum entropy principle we done so
it's a the basic idea is so right now
our purpose is to try to estimate the
joint probability of all the observation
of the difference tree so if we have a
difficulty to calculate them because you
know that the difference between have
the different time scale give the
metrical ever even put together maybe
it's a high dimensionality space so we
can use the approximate method so so in
this equation we the joint probability
of the observation was boxing editor by
the first turn is the product of the
probability of the component of the
different streams and then the second
return is is to try to how to set the
categorize the correlation on a
different string if we did this second
turn actually this is a this is a
decision ever diffusion this is a it's
kind of thing so we model independent
and combined at the end so we use the
second in turn try to characterize the
correlation among the different streams
so the W is a how to choose the w
there's the two criteria why is the W
should reflect the correlation among the
different streams another criteria so
that means that they can categorize the
correlation another criteria is should
be easy to calculate and the original
join the probability so this is a
two-car theory they choose to W so you
I'll task the W does have a two choice
the W we can choose the double equals 0
and 0 choose the hidden state if we
model the the streams by hmm model so
the different a choice we get a
different representation of of the of
the multimodal filtering the problem so
if we choose the w all the W equals to 0
so then we become the original problem
to estimate the joint probability if we
choose the w all the w are the hidden
state so that means that we try to use
the correlation amount the hidden stays
of a different string that basically
it's becoming the capo hmm coverage even
just to try to model the decoration of
the of the hidden states so my choice is
a between name we choose them for
example for the stream streaming one we
choose the w 1 equals the hidden state
and the other tap you are the
observation so that means the way trying
to collect to calculate the correlation
make use the correction of the
though the hidden state of one string
and the observation of the other string
so we try to use the Kabul the parameter
of the dehiscent here instead of one
string and the opportunity to other
string so we we can argued in this way
is much better than the couple hmm model
because the based on the maximum the
mutual information we notice if we use
the for example the this we used to you
and other use the observation this we
can get the the bad the mutual
information awful better mutual
information then if we choose the w or
the WR are hidden state so this is the
basic idea of the future chairman so
when the cub will build the model of the
component component hmm always make use
of the couple of the correlational of
this hidden state and others the
observation of the other strings so have
any question ok so here is you that
example soon why a one on top of is what
you see with you you want a chain so ok
tell nessa it's always you all right and
then I'm sorry Tommy wanted to go one of
the few
n equal to 0 0 mmm-hmm so that means the
emulator and the target event second
npos would be vessel for 4i problem from
two okay okay let's uh let's have have
the tool hidden the slides I think I can
show you baby miss the mark ok so I'll
for example we try to build the
component a German are for the I
component a German so we we use the w j
and j is equal I which is the you hidden
state and the other j not equal to i its
just oh so so we can diffuse model you
will get this a equation so for example
we can put off them into the equation so
this is a you other is oh right this is
the you this is Otto so we can get this
equation so we can some one week until
it right and oh so someone deleted the
pio pio pio I still there and other one
so for example 01 you can't it either I
00 200 in working till it so we can get
this at equation so that means the first
this joint probability we can
approximate the first is the appeal and
another another second return it is
given the UI what kind of a probability
of off to all of the other streams we
can get this equation
period when Bonnie depends on the
previous observations you mean the pain
yeah out there you can also just
eviscerate the stream there yeah so
actually the sequence right mm-hmm
actually its sequence so okay I can okay
give you the learning algorithm
politican it's helpful to explain resell
this algorithm so the northern algorithm
we should first we build the component a
German our training independently by da
mega ridden and then we are in for the
hidden state the best the hidden state
using the Viterbi algorithm and then we
we are calculating the cut of covering
parameters bhatinda and a terminar esta
made by this one because so then is the
given the state or the observation of
the oh
so it's kind of a straightforward so
always here also did some okay right now
we wait okay Nestor so we we try to
estimate this joint probability we make
this choice so we can get the
approximation of the nation is first
there are the probability of independent
the stream and then the second attorney
is a it's a given again given the you
the hidden state of I string and what
kind of probability of the other
observation so this we also make a
little simplified so because this one we
use the conditional independence so we
simplified to here and then so the
finally we get this equation so the
joint probability can be estimated by p
0 and the product of contingently
conditional probability so what a person
is is looking for yourself right and
then she is if he had I so that let us
not to use you you is not impatient but
now I'm right who sadly for you there so
that's some title so you mean front here
to the to the last minute hawk phunkee
eyes ya if ya I don't see what you are
worried you console so okay so sit here
just like the output was like that one
they stay here but now or a salon right
you play you either so this okay okay
actually disappear okay you mean the PI
right so actually to condition you i
right
oh ok so so this is this you I so so
here it's a for example we use this UI
here sorry
so I mean you mean so right now we
choose to hear the one the stream the W
which was the UI so this is no question
here right you have you question here is
how to gather the UI right here sorry so
here is no you guys not here I mean this
discontent is not already if you are man
is this you are it's you I is actually
are implicitly included Visser it's
exactly this is this it's a implicitly
include this equation because I you feel
I'll calculate this the joint
probability you must be because you use
the hidden a marker model so this you
are here you must estimate right video
you want you guys ok ok ok this is ok
this is the Naga ribbon so you see right
now we are independent to train the
atrium wonderful each of the stream
right so we get the best the hidden
state of sequence you I of the
combination so you yeah yeah we'll pick
up the UI this is the best estimate of
the heat estate so so ok you should have
mentioned this before they ok thank you
yeah so okay yes i'll experiment result
we did personally independent experiment
used to leave one subject how the
cross-validation the method and also we
have we choose the three streams three
components streets jeans and a beauty
the three-component a vm model why is
the video hmm model which is made up of
12 virtual motion units and another the
peach a german energy hmm so we have the
sweet come bowlin hmm
so we combine them once they use the
multi strand independent hmm model which
is based on the independence of the
different strains another is a motive
fused multi-storey in the fuse hmm model
so are also investigated the performance
had a different never noise so what's
recognition accuracy on what the
accuracy is on acoustic lessons and I
chrissy's how to how these classes are
already okay okay uh I saw you haven't
classes mm-hmm so so we so we are
artificially added a white noise in the
audio channel so you will see the future
hmm and the energy a feminine the
performance decreased with the 30
degrees of the SNR DP from the 25 DB to
the zero DP so the the pitcher and
energy hmm is decreased the visual hmm
keep constant because the we just added
the noise in the audio channel so the
independent hmm model it's a rather than
most of the time get the developer
phones in the Uni the streamed component
hmm model but when the when the signal
noise ratio is lower than the five TB is
worst together the worst performance
then the video hmm but the few sites
when one has the best performance is
always better than the Uni string and
independent asian model so i don't
understand the hearing
in the independent nation is infused
Eliza worse than video on because you
know so few knows actually the when the
some de our individual the streams very
worse this the combination also take a
risk because you know because of the for
example you for the one Kamala lecture
is much higher but another stream there
is another component is rich lower you
combine together maybe because it that
you can get in couple nights under you
guide the meal so this is a tick risk so
this is the possible yeah but if I take
a invite choose the weeds optimally oh
you know okay I drinking at all although
oh yeah this is not about you that I I
get worse good north end yeah yeah so
you fool you can monitor you can robusta
estimated a reliability of a different
string you can adjust the weight not
together the the paper form is a fool
you we choose here the weight is just
the a problem proportional to the
accuracy of the of the string of the
component streams so in the many
challenges parts of the multiplication
of nature it's rated R different
variables it's waning combination it's
big the graduates are always other
accuracy yeah the witness a quiz on the
validation set or random under test it's
a okay okay this in this expander we are
with validation and at the training use
the same Jadeja yeah because I mean
these multiplication rules are very
prone to overfitting and
Bates like these so that might be a big
problem and that's one of the folder
mmhmm yeah maybe probably might make
sense let's travel like a modulation
said so yeah if we have them no more
later it's a better to divided it to
testing the how to say to the invalid
data and the generator please product of
each event independent it's just looking
at the sum of likelihood which is much
too robust noise mm-hmm because in
multiplication the fact that you make
one of the Asian and goes to zero
everything goes to zero if you're
looking at Sun so but basically that's a
sort of a version of a I mean there's a
technique for I can power to you that
says that in case of noises in a Leo you
should use addition rather than
multiplications yeah yeah so yeah this
is a but how to say to our robust
estimated of of the reliability of the
different strings and at the open
question so right now we just use a
simple to accuracy yeah so another the
issue awakes rod is right now which is
very simple the combination we just
combine together actually the product of
Negritude or another way to the
summation of log leg hood and put the
weight here oh so it's a it's a it's a
it's a take a risk sometimes it doesn't
work well if but anyway we tried another
ways right now if we use the training
scheme to build the combination it is
able to calibrate the output of of the
component output the of the different
components so we use the different the
training skill to build the combiner we
caught the train the combiner so that's
a it's a we tried the issue to improve
the performance by to use the train to
combine so in this case we can see the
output of the different modality as the
input of a classifier and the Takata
class is it is how does it out police
the target class so we use the different
training differ the training skill to
view this train the combiner so here is
our experiment the first is a uni
strained hmm model and then we use the
fixed combiner this is the way the
weight is proportional to the accuracy
and then we use the because they use the
different actually we use the Gaussian
combination and the visual combination
the build is a train the combiner so
you're not expanding the train the
combiner is it's a little better than
the fixed combiner because it's a is
able to calibrate the output of the
defender modality
so the fission the Gaussian the
combination means that are we modeled it
should targeted classes biased how to
say based on the we use the Gaussian
distribution to model the targeted the
Egypt it should each attack that
targeted classes are modeled by the
Gaussian distribution and the feature
the Madoff use the hmm memorial it's a
house that we use the official classify
yes yes yes so okay oh here I showed
some accuracy of the different emotions
especially with we are located so in the
in our experiment the cognitive states
especially the frustration interested in
the ball have the worst performance so
we also notice the subject actually have
the difficulty to express this kind of
autonomous days by choosing use the face
expression it's very difficult for
example if I asking you to explain
interesting how to express the
frustration how to express the ball so
it's a very difficult so actually in
this kind of situation the audio is a
contributor more than the visual part
it's a post it's also supposed even I
ask for you to post for interest rate
it's very difficult so it's so the audio
part is the more important in this kind
of situation so
measurement to measure the distance
between different classes so for example
you say these three classes are given
from two to differentiate between have
seen some measurements and distance say
usually those two classes as much as
much smaller measurements oh you mean
the confusion matrix oh yeah yes we have
a confusion about that initial here you
can see the resulting in our paper yeah
you mean the confusion matrix so what
kind of how to say it's what kind what
again the tool to the straighter are
easily confused or not right what what
kind of something cooking objective to
perform those emotions which media okay
this is a student and also faculty
actually they are not actor so this is
justice student in the university and
the faculty of staff they because those
emotions me I tell they're all that this
all blips worries animators prostrate on
your frustrated you know oh we can be
frustrated and angry at the same time
happy can you be happy with fluttering
Oh
but if you have young interested that's
all yeah yeah this is nitrous yeah but
usually this one too many car or a chain
white people oh this is that we just use
it you know the we just had them use the
maxim and the neck road to the to be the
criteria so if the net hood away if you
know so one classifier this is my
typical class problem yes but ok we just
choose to mention in the next for
example this model this is drivin you
have to tell you have to tell the motor
right which model get the the heist is
anger my self-interest this one but you
also have obtained classifier on top of
HMS right so that's a binary classifier
it'll put me tell me the combination the
one that you were talking about
combining when you're training and your
training those ways using the Fisher
discriminant or okay okay who's our
binary classifiers the minor those are
sir sorry I mean how are you combine me
when you are combining multiple hmm is
using different ways right hmm assess
first single for single classes that's
what single class friends or every class
you have a showing that this is the
house that generating more generative
model so you just the the choose the one
with the heist little likelihood to the
night the higher the probability so
Boston's hmm then probably choosing the
Martin with the maximum biking because
it made sense mm-hmm yeah just adjust
the class with the highest probability
so this is a little summary about the
Madoff you say chairman so the by model
can be other performant individualist
stream and fusarium n is multi fuses it
fills a few min outperform the
multiscreen the independent a german
twin a combiner could be possible for
the outperform the fixed combiner and
mostly important feature is the brown
woman in the video channel and the pitch
energy in the audio channel i sell us
the from the one to say I think the
average or the the duration of the
expression is about one second to second
to second
oh hey swear what you say oh oh okay Oh
for example the happy thank you computer
you are very helpful this so it's it's a
Content a to help the subject to you to
post this expression yes because if we
if without the proper the content
subject is very difficult to express
their there are they in you rotten
recognition you know it's all worse
every worse oh no nothing trying so
because you miss a scenario it's because
especially we wanted to induce the house
they also won the Oscar subjects
including stressed you haven't affected
state seats it's very difficult if you
have a properly the content is very
difficult to express so anyway in in our
expandable just use a pitcher an injured
so we didn't use the spell good words so
yeah by the way the door people oh she
doesn't data they're actually Oscar the
actor / friend actor hmm just say the
same sentence I'm just different
emotions uh-huh yeah all of you like us
we cannot do it yes yeah actor Jack good
yeah yeah so listen so because yet
active they are trained to do this kind
of thing so they know how to express the
difference between a expressions but for
the normal people it's very difficult
how do mobilisation save different
people even for different emotions they
so express this okay okay so because the
head of the beginning whereas it is
subjected to neutral to express the new
to expression so this is a neutral
expression is a baseline for the for the
recognition so that means the the mean
of the Challenger can be used as
standard so the other lotion expression
which is that we just cover the
difference between them so when I'm Meg
you said the female and male have a
different picture and amateur so we just
used the neutral expression as the as
the baseline a visual feature we also
have to how to say we have the neutral
face so it is a cabriolet different than
the between the neutral face i'm still
keep you are different though yeah so
extent change variable given its best
means somebody avoid expressive yes some
people waste arrows ball you're right
you're saying like some killed my son
same makeup same village no matter what
is happy you're silent as a matter he so
ask you to call I guess some people do
some someone really stressing someone
like yeah you're right alright so so
this is a my question so we use the
neutral expression as the baseline even
the face and audio heart so next the
sexting I will talk about a multi-view
facial expression analysis so especially
when they are how to say when i move to
efforts from the poster emotion to the
spontaneous expression will face a lot
of challenger one challenger is how to
say we must handle the arbitrary
movement of a subject because you know
the spontaneous is you cannot ask you
something
you know how do they expressly the
motion in front of the camera because
something most of the time the camera
was hidden so the arm so this is a kind
of an upstream movement of subject it's
a challenging the existing methods at
which most of them based on the front of
you front of you are expressions so we
build the assistant who can handle the
mark view of facial expression is the
way to solve this problem so the one
question which I each of the us most is
whether the non front of you that
expression analysis can gather equal the
better performance than the front of you
facial expression analysis this is the
question 16 straw so here I did the let
me do a perception human perception
experiment I show a bunch of from
imagers which is a fake expression at a
different view angle so here is so so
tell me what the view you think it is
the best for you to understand the fish
expression so here it's a profile view
of the facial expression and then this
this is the subject that expressed there
are six basically motion so it's a in
this from the profile view it's a I
think you will feel the difficult little
to interpret the face expression let me
tell a little bit so we get this angle
view and then attended in a bit so you
all feel much better right because you
care the more and more to the video cube
so then this is a the front of you
facial expression so what's the best of
you what's the best perspective for you
and send this a facial expression from
so oh yeah the most people we also ok
the front of you should be the the best
of you for human understand taking fish
expression because that seems that they
give you them the most visible Q so so
my father is the front of you is the
best of it is the best perspective for
the machines and stand the facial
expression so we did expand the based on
the a sweetie data sweetie facial
expression database which was to collect
the by professor in the bin Laden
University so the database include the
one sub 1 the subject was it even the
rhesus and they ask you the subject to
express a new channel 6 basically
emotions with the full level of
intensity and we use this database to
generate the multi-vue the facial
expression we focus on right now is the
front the ER rotation we generally the
five view angle from the front of you to
the prior profile view in ice famine we
use the menu labeled official point so
it's official points it's a menu labeled
just it's around the mouse I and eyebrow
oh we use this the the menu labeled
feature point it's a feature and we have
our 12,000 the imagers including the 100
subject 60 motion the full ever of our
intensity and the five angle so this is
a personal independent are the emotion
recognition performance we use the
fivefold across validation the
this axis representing the wii the
defender classified we used two
different classify and I from the LDC
cute QDC and the person and svm and now
we use the KN and I applied the cane in
different the subspace original piece
al-tal PP and this axis represented the
view angle fun let's include 0 3rd
degree 45 degree and 6th degree and a 90
degree so this is the accuracy so in
this extremity you will notice the best
of you for the Machine and standing is
not the front of you actually it's a
it's a long front of you you will know
this is exactly this QDC the best of you
is 60 degree the other to classify will
get the best performance it's a 45 for
the five degree so okay this one is also
the person needs it's not the 45 degree
but anyway it's a non front of you so
the feature we used to how to say we use
the manual labor the feature so is that
suit is a gun too we see with support
and yes those bones okay so i get it i
did a compression on time ago mm-hmm so
I compare data points hmm with the cable
will read ah another reason could give
you much much better without their plans
already okay yeah yeah it says we see
this awful stuff so I decide anything
naturally the funds to see an emotion I
brought was much easier for us to see
that the cheekbone watching mm-hmm very
very clear to us we
sup receive that but you probably
already started machines to just adjust
plans do you want to give it a point hmm
you just got a point for us it's hotter
fast people I shouldn't tell which one's
better right what of us / Gannett
expression nomas he presented the image
here pigeon soon because it would look
at some other magicians point mm-hmm
that's good yeah this is a possible
explanation so so another let's see duh
oh here is that and how does it perform
the Tiffin the emotions are based on the
svm classifier this is the best to
classify in our task so also get the the
best type of women's and the 45 degree
so the surprise and the happy oh Jesus
state it will recognize the anger and
fear is a it's a most difficult to
recognize so so anyway so you nice
experiment the result is struggles
enormously because it's a different
front of intuition so because your
intuition is how to say it the front of
you show you the best of you but right
now we can so yeah so that this is a
facility so anyway this is interesting
the result and so yeah like you said in
some way because the non front of you
can give the depth so information about
the face and for the front of you the
depth is totally lost so this is a
possible explanation but another the
psychotics furnishing is I think it done
is that you know human the face-to-face
communication most of the time we just
use the displayed of the front view of
the face expression right because
because for example we're talking here I
face I give you my frontal face to you
right because I can I talk I contact
with you right
that's very important you fly just a
turn around so you cannot make sense so
you don't like it don't lie look at me
you will look at the screen so so you
know daily life it seems to the how to
say the most you major about the fish
expression at the front of your face so
that leaves the lead to the how to say
it human perception the bios so the
people are more sensitive to the to the
front of you the facial expression of
the face so this is a possibility
explanation from the psychology to the
perspective but the better you're not
experiment we give the equal number
equal number of training examples for
each for each of use so they evaluate it
in the failed platform so the last work
how well did introduce is the
spontaneous or the visual the expression
analysis so you may ask one of the
difference between the poster expression
in a spontaneous question I show some
video to you so
thank your computer you have been very
helpful okay haha i wish you another
supposed to discuss this background
color looks awful give me a different
color so when you're watching this video
is all this is a fake that's a totally
fake because they did the subject how
does they exaggerate his expression
right but the spontaneous expression
this is the question dancer is another
killer that's a worry ah so us it's a
it's it's so different my dad when he
wasn't really like that so well known is
know how to say this voluntary
expressions more shuttle is more subtle
and they have the different visual
appearance and the different time
profile even the audio and visual so
this is so different and so this is why
the people right now okay shifted the
efforts from the post expression to the
spontaneous Russian when we try to build
the system it can walk that you know
Delhi why we must face this a challenger
although spontaneous expression is very
difficult by the way we must face this
challenge so we did the preliminaries to
study in in this direction well use the
data from the adult attachment
attachment interview which was conducted
in a professor Roizman in the UIUC on so
in this scenario the subject that was
asked was a week while to describe the
childhood is especially he's the happy
experience the sad experience or
something so it's a the camera was
hidden in the black class so although
anyway did any subject that have a
signed agreement but they they didn't
know the where with the camera so that's
so we can capture the real the
expression here you now experiment that
we choose the data of the two
takes one male and a female the video
lasts about the 40 minutes so the first
the problem we had to face is if you if
you try the puter system to recognize
six basic emotions you will be very
disappointed because you cannot gather
enough data for these basic emotions
because then you know the sixth
basically moja happy sad if your anger
and the surprise is extremely expression
so you normal the human to human
communication you cannot find a surprise
you have not found it the angry the fear
so so it's very difficult so um so most
of the expression are very subtle so we
turn out to our so we turned to my
efforts to computer system to recognize
just a positive and enact if the
emotions so so you know this is a it's a
total different up from the post of the
expression analysis and another another
question another challenge we have to
face the delivery though for the post
expression because you asked the people
to happy ok this is this expression
shuttle should be the happy ok but I'll
when you face this again the spontaneous
expression so the how-to to label them
you know the even the agreement of the
label it's not so high the labor in the
main library of the small Tennessee is
for ambiguity unfortunately how you mean
this self-report yeah oh sorry about
this yeah used so used to in some
psychology or the research but you know
if we want try to ask them to to
self-report the Lego they are expression
the frame by frame the second by second
it's not sometimes it's not possible
yeah he can give the most of the time we
just how to say when the other side
after interview the welcome to the forum
the generous so during this interview
the one kind of expression did you have
experienced so that's that's okay but
you cannot ask them for labor the second
by second the expression so it's enough
hospital well I was doing my PhD so
you're building crime trying to figure
out assistant you recognize frustration
in users so you know I someone's
interacting with the system and they
have a button right there you know I'm
frustrated quit they cigna so the user
themselves go and so that's a positive
point you know that one positive point
but the way the way we went to analyze
the data was that all right we have one
positive point for rest of the data we
don't really know so but still that's an
information right a user and explicitly
provided that's ground truth and from
that you can kind of you know sort of
get some data about what is mental
strain was but this has been one of the
problems i think the speed right how to
get the ground rules and in fact like
when I work with coded as well even just
trying to come up with a protocol that
everyone would agree consistently on as
itself a very challenging tasks and
unfortunately not much not much IQ work
has been focused and just trying to get
the label data so that you can benefit
and business and spoons so yeah this is
actually there's some the message to
carry the laboring especially the I
noticed that there's people who how to
say use the video to induce the sum
expression for example you watch the
comedy movie maybe you can that can
induce the heck but the in this kind of
situation you just again a facial
expression because this is not the
interaction the setting so the the
subject was passive to watch the video
and no
you know it is the most effective way of
psychology literature yeah that's one of
the very sort of popular ways of
illustrating emotions but again those I
mean those studies are very hard to
control for I mean the thing is you know
you you can hope that those emotions
will be elucidated but you can't
guarantee Yeah right and but but it's an
effective way I think probably in like
in computer science domain also this
should be probably one of the methods
that you should be looking in you just
ask you with the labels of movies yeah
yeah yeah it's it yeah this isn't so
anyway so the delivery is very
Challenger are so fortunately we have
the facial coding facial action coding
system which was developed by the pole
argument who divided with this is
certain to measure the visual appearance
by the action units so it's it's a kind
of object description of the facial
expression but the problem is the audio
part right now so far let us know this
kind of the coding system the object to
label the signal so you know in our
experiment we make this kind of
assumption it's a facial expression the
vocal expression at the same the cost
effective station and the positive and a
negative emotion so this assumption we
made it in our experiment another is a
segmentation this apartment is also very
Challenger because you know how to
second a need for the automatic
assistant so wait segmented this was
segmented this the i use the two
criterion one is how to say muster the
physics i the the expression is the
intensity must be our is higher than the
threshold another is how to say it
because you know the same problem the
opportunity movement we cannot control
so we just a segmented that the video
it's almost near front of you know
occlusion
so this is we must be some compromise to
feed out the limitation of our technical
so the framework I used to use the to
stream the hidden Markov model Oh for
the for the visual pathway notice
because the the facial expression is
very subtle so if we just use the other
12 action Union 12 motion units it's not
enough to to capture this the start of
expression so we we use the will also
use the 3d fish tracker but this time we
warp the texture of the whole face so
use this to hold the texture of the face
as the feature and then we used this
dimension this is a this is this is a
whopper the texture of the of the face
and then we use the dimensional
reduction the methods the PCN lpp to
project the high dimensional imager to
the low dimensional subspace and due to
the visual hmm for the other party will
use the porosity and then build the
audio a treatment and then the fusion
power we try everything so we tried just
to fix the fixed combiner and our
training combiner here we used just how
to say are the way to the combiner and
the last the three the combination is
between it's a trainer combiner we use
LDC k and and at boost to to try to
every way to improve this performance of
the spontaneous expression so here i am
in a result way to the personal
depending experiment because we have
adjusted to subject so we use the little
one sequence out cross validation the
first is the hm berman in the pcs
subspace we get basic this extreme and
you you know the even the subject have
the different subject have different
the performance because the different
subject has a different how the
expression ability and especially you
you you all know this the mail it's
right it's more expressive of the female
is more expressive and then we tried
this is a visual hmm a in the LPP
subspace and the worst of harder is
audio the audio agen have the the
Worcester performance this is a
reasonable because the wooden a label
the day we lived at ax we did not use to
ending the information about the audio
so another way is people also argued
when we face this about an expression
the prosody is not enough to to
calculate the expression so we get the
worst the performance of the audio aged
women ish and energy outperform lot
uh-huh you mean
you mean what what's your question
that's much less use oh because okay so
for the spontaneous they said this is a
true i think the nest possible
explanation why is because the
spontaneous but anyway when label a data
we didn't we just use the facial action
coding system to label data so that
means the labouring we didn't used we
didn't use it any information on the
audio expression another is a maybe the
porosity it's not enough so it's what
okay almost ok hmm so we tried the fixed
combiner you know actually use the the
combiner use over in this kind of
situation you also take risk it's it's a
it's a even the female the combiner
because you are the audio part is the
problem so so bad so the combination is
it's not helpful and we tried to train
the combiner so we see that's a lot of
there's a different performance even the
train the combiner so some some some
worse some better so anyways for for
this kind of a super 10 is the
expression recognition how the beauty
the optimal diffusion model it's it's
very challenger it says still need the
further investigation so let me
summarize them I talk so in this talk I
first we'll talk about the history of
the effect the recognition research we
indicate I point out there's two trends
here why is the multimodal effective
recognition another it is about a nice
expression analysis and I talked about
it multi-screen the future
which is to make use of a correlation of
the different streams and we talked a
multi-storey infuse the multiscreen the
facial expression analysis which is we
express the question whether the non
front of you facial expression can get
either equal the better performance than
the front of you officials expression
analysis and then I introduce the
perennial preliminary result about the
spontaneous expression analysis so
there's a lot of challenger here if we
wait to the Samba spontaneous expression
research-wise the database especially
the library for example you feel if
we'll watch this imager I ask you what
is the effective States is this subject
that expressed maybe the confusion
frustration to anything because I you
have no contacts so this is the why the
reason the context is very important
what what well he still he's doing what
kind of environment he's so so it's very
important so for the visual based
analysis we talk about especially how to
build the decision to handle the
opportunity movement of the subject it's
a needed the further investigation and
the audio base the analysis we needed to
integrate the linguist and apparel
English the features but anyway how to
get a robust together this kind of
feature it's an open question especially
there's even the the spoken words we can
not on so a condor speech rag on our
recognition system cannot reliably to
get it as the spoken words so even for
the some linguistic summary information
is is we can just inferred from the
cementing a context for example to
discuss information but how to get it
it's it's very Challenger another is how
to build is the the optimum diffusion
methods for this and
this problem it's a is still largely
unexplored another is a context when an
award will and why and who so but anyway
although we faced a lot of a challenger
in this research that's still hope there
if we constrain our task for the
specific domain like a detective fatigue
in the driving situation detector may be
confusing the learning environment
detector frustration in the gaming
system maybe there is a hope because we
have a lot of constraint I've good night
you about about the contacts so this is
this hope here for I'm optimistic about
the future of this research so I want a
larger my club or collaborators it gave
me a lot of support and encouragement to
explore this complicated of the problem
so if you are interested in this my walk
you can visit my website and then they
gather the people especially I I
strongly recommended the survey paper
where did it recently so that has been
accepted in I trap hydro blazer
transaction on the pattern analysis and
admission and machine intelligence so
you read the paper you will get a whole
picture about what happened in this
field what the Challenger we have the
face what kind of database is available
for your research so this end of my talk
thank you